cela a commencé avec la peste noire en quelques
semaines, les morts ont commencé à ressusciter, ce bétail
chasse la chair humaine,
maintenant le peu d'entre nous qui reste n'ont
qu'un seul moyen de survivre, nous devons
leur mener le combat. Je me suis entraîné pour
cela tout mon temps.  la vie, les choix d'épouse les plus justes
soient ici, dans cette pièce, mes
filles se sont entraînées au combat, monsieur,
pas à la cuisine, une femme doit avoir une
connaissance approfondie du chant, de la danse
et de l'art de la guerre, je n'abandonnerai jamais
mon épée pour une bague, c'est vrai,
tu irais
bien  l'homme ne me demanderait pas de partir,
je ne sais pas lequel j'admire le plus ton
talent de guerrier, tu connais le service
un